[Music]
nicole's in michigan i started a home
bakery earlier this year i'm wanting to
move my bakery to a restaurant space
serving breakfast and lunch as well as
our baked good offerings i'll be dumping
all my savings into this restaurant and
going all in
am i making a wise decision to use all
my savings on this dream
well nicole um
you don't want your dream to become a
nightmare
failure
is a part of business
if you're in business you're going to
have failure the trick is to have
non-fatal failure
don't have a failure that takes you out
and that the way you solve that trick is
the size of the failure
so have lots and lots and lots of little
algie's instead of one where you lose
your head
don't get taken out all my savings means
i have no money
that's not good nicole
because here's the three rules of
business
rule number one of business it takes
twice as long as you think it's going to
rule number two it costs twice as much
as you think it's going to
rule number three you're not the
exception
so when you move into this little
restaurant and you've got it all figured
out and you have exactly enough just to
open the doors
you're going to run out of money and go
broke
because it's going to take longer than
you thought it was going to because your
projections are based on a wet finger in
the air you don't know what this thing's
going to produce the only thing you know
is what you've been producing
with your home bakery
earlier this year so my suggestion would
be
and you're not going to like it because
everybody wants to go fast and not slow
but my suggestion would be run that home
bakery a little bit longer pile up a
little more money
a lot more money get your recipes and
your customer base
dialed in
know more about the business than you
know nine months after you opened it
it's still a little baby business
it just started it's cute but we don't
want to pledge our whole thing on the
back of this baby business i've done
stupid stuff like this kid that's how i
know i got a phd in dumb
i have done so much stuff that has cost
me money
and lost money and i have become an
expert in the last five years about
making smaller mistakes
because most of my mistakes have been
colossal yes some of my failures have
been or some of my successes have been
colossally large as well
but um
i'm convinced that we are where we are
based on about 10 of our best ideas the
other 90 sucked
and when you're in the shower or on the
running trail all your ideas sound smart
in your head
so please go slower please don't move in
with no money and hope you're going to
be okay lack of liquidity lack of
retained earnings to survive a downturn
your little uh town that you're in could
have a little coveted hiccup and
somebody decided to go all communists
and shut the whole place down and then
you'd be out of business and your
savings is all gone
and so there you go
and you've got to have a little more
wiggle room than you got right now and
your business is not big enough
dial it up dial it up dial it up and
then launch it so if i were you if you
were my daughter and i were sitting down
with you i would say live your dream
baby but don't make it a nightmare
i want you to own a bakery for the rest
of your life and be successful and be
highly popular and written up in
magazines as the finest baker in the
world and everybody's got to go to
nicole's place over on 4th avenue or
wherever it is i want that to be you
and your best route to get there is wait
one more year at least
get your customer base up
begin to tease them about what's coming
coming next year
coming in 23 coming attractions
on the next episode of nicole's bakery
that's what you tease them build up
build your base build your tribe
and build your money and you'll have a
much better
experience with your life